in this video we're going to talk about
how to find the vertices of a triangle
when you're given the midpoints of the
sides we're going to be talking about
the mid segment theorem so let's just
take a triangle like this for example if
we find the midpoint of this side so
that these two are congruent and we find
the midpoint of this side so that these
two segments are congruent and we
connect those two midpoints this length
that I'm drawing right here is referred
to as a mid segment and what's
interesting about the mid segment is
that it's going to be half of this base
and it's also going to be par parallel
to that base now if I find the midpoint
of this side and I connect these two
this becomes a mid segment and it's
parallel to this side and it's going to
be half as long so that means that this
length this length and this length are
congruent and then if I look at these
two midpoints that's a mid segment
that's going to be parallel to this side
over here and it's going to be half as
long so the key is it's parallel and
half of that other side so let's take a
look at an example now so say for
example we have a triangle like this one
right here and what we want to do is we
want to find the uh actual triangle so
these points represent the midpoints
okay and so these are like our mid
segments but how do we get the original
Triangle Well what we're going to do is
we're going to go ahead and pay
attention to the fact that this mid
segment is going to be parallel to the
base so if I go over here up to this
other uh midpoint what I'm going to do
is I'm going to look at the slope of
this mid segment I'm going to say rise
one run three so if I repeat that
pattern rise one run three and I put a
point here and I can do the same thing
down one and left three that's also the
same slope of 1/3 and if I connect those
that's the side of our triangle so for
example if this slope here is let's see
Rise three run -2 so I went up three
left two I repeat that same process rise
three left two and I can can also go the
other direction I can go down three and
right two so that's the same slope and
if I connect
those that's the side of our triangle
and then you could repeat it again you
could say well let's look at this uh mid
segment right here this has a slope of
one two 3 4 run one so if I repeat that
rise four run one or I could go down
four left one but you can see we already
have those um vertices of the triangle
so that's how you would construct the
triang triangle given the midpoints of
the triangle or you could be given these
mid segments here and you got it so I
hope that helps you to understand the
mid segment theorem and how to construct
the triangle given those midpoints I'll
see you in the next video